cette photo là c'est une une vue de la
cordillère blanche prix de la cordillère
noir un bruyant courtois au sommet de sa
passion avec 24 ascension à son actif
jacques draperies a parcouru l'équateur
la bolivie le pérou et l'argentine entre
5000 et 7000 mètres d'altitude
de quoi avoir les yeux dans le ciel des
andes d'après le titre de son livre
tous les soirs après chaque ascension
j'ai toujours j'écrivais toujours ce que
le choses un compte rendu de la journée
et puis après la conca gua je me suis
dit tiens je vais je vais relire mes
petites menottes et puis je me suis dit
je pourrais laisser une petite trace
pour ma famille donc j'ai commencé à
écrire à écrire un livre paru en
décembre 2015 ouvrage retrace les
expéditions américaine de l'alpiniste
entre 2006 et 2013 en partageant son
expérience
comment on s'y préparer comment on
s'acclimate donc au début c'est
l'organisation comment on organise une
expédition
quand on doit tout mettre en mettre en
place et ensuite raconté tout ce que
j'ai pu ressentir pendant ses pendants
ces expulsions et les erreurs que j'ai
fait malgré mes connaissances de la
montagne avec des vents de près de 150
km heure et des températures avoisinant
les moins 35 degrés des situations
périlleuses peuvent apparaître
il arrive un moment où il faut prendre
des décisions lorsqu'on est dans un dans
un environnement qui est difficile une
tempête c'est arrivé la première fauche
partie au pérou on s'est retrouvé à
sciez à plus de 6000 mètres dans une
tempête de neige il est trouvé 50 cm de
neige en une heure et demie deux heures
il a fallu faire demi tour
aujourd'hui j'ai appris à doser à deux
aimants l'effort je me connais très bien
en montagne comme comme dans l'effort
physique et en fait on puise dans le
mental pour faire face à ce genre de
situation attiré par le défi des sceaux
mais la découverte de la nature
jacques draperies pourrait repartir en
expédition pour accroître son palmarès
montagneux